democrats being accused of playing dumb
on the surge in crime after speaker
nancy pelosi seemed to be unaware of
where it's coming from
it's absolutely outrageous you know
obviously it cannot continue
but the fact is that there is an
attitude of uh
lawlessness in our country that springs
from i don't know where
maybe you do
and we cannot have that lawlessness
become the norm pelosi apparently
forgetting what members of her own party
have been saying for months
not only do we need to defund but we
need to dismantle and start a new
talking about um the reduction of our
nypd budget and defunding a six billion
dollar nypd budget oh yes i support the
defund movement because this is about
the
the um
investment
in our communities which have
historically been divested
i am for defunding the police defund the
police does not mean abolish the police
it means a dramatic reduction in the
number of police in our poor communities
wherever what does the increase in crime
have come from judge
i don't even know what to say these
people are living in another planet
what's so disturbing is that inner city
crime where uh african americans and
minorities live are hit the hardest when
police are defunded when the anti-crime
units the street crime units are not
activated these people are lying to the
american people when they say defunding
the police is is you know shouldn't
affect i'm reading here shouldn't affect
the safety it doesn't mean we don't want
public safety well that's hogwash
because if they don't believe that
police are providing safety who do they
think is providing the safety first of
all we've got to get people to make sure
that this bail so-called bail reform
which is a euphemism for let them all
out of jail is is uh repealed and we go
back to bail and we've got to make sure
that all of these laws in california and
we started this with nancy pelosi where
she says i don't know where this came
from do you i'm curious as to who she
was talking to but when you have a law
in a state that says crime in the amount
or theft in the amount of 950 or less is
not prosecutable you have george soros
da's who are not prosecuting crime
you're going to have lawlessness and
you're going to have absolute anarchy
and chaos it cannot change until we
change the laws and get rid of these
people who for their own selfless
reasons are deciding or arguing that
we're not safe with police as if they're
serial racist murderers they're not
jesse on many issues it seems that they
never connect their policy to the
outcome no that means she only cares
about crime when it comes to her
doorstep remember they smashed and
grabbed on january 6th in her office a
little bit what'd you do she thought
about lawlessness then she impeached the
president she put fences up everywhere
threw everybody with a maga hat in
prison she knew exactly what happened
then but kenosha goes up in flames
doesn't say anything you know david
doran gets shot in the head doesn't say
anything doesn't care what happens to
your neighborhood but if it comes to her
gated estate if it comes to her vineyard
or wherever she works then she's going
to say something once you're older
you're supposed to be wiser she's been
around what the 70s crime wave the crack
epidemic she saw what rudy did here in
new york city in the 90s she knows what
it takes the crime bill that joe biden
did in the 90s she knows what to do
she's just too busy eating her little
ice cream look at her stock portfolio by
the way she's worth a hundred million
dollars now since she became a
congresswoman that's lawlessness that's
a crime we should look into that i agree
that's what we should be really focused
on but you know you look into that
i know i know where the attitude of
lawlessness is coming from where i
remember i i used to be uh married to
the daughter of kurt vonnegut the the
great author of slaughterhouse five and
many other uh uh novels he was uh from a
pacifist family so in virgo house fight
about that world war ii he wrote about
how
the soldiers went and including some of
these pacifist soldiers and they killed
the enemy and the heavens didn't open up
as they had been taught the heavens
would there was not a lightning bolt
there was not instant punishment for the
sinner who who violated the uh you know
the ten commandments and so forth i
think that's the problem there is a
disconnect between the act and morality
now there's no consequence anymore uh
because if you don't prosecute
there's no consequence someone figures
it out and they say oh i can steal that
you know you've always looked at that
gucci bag in there well just take it
it can be yours you don't have to worry
about uh the morality of it anymore you
don't have to worry about law and order
anymore because it's irrelevant but
brian where did the lack of prosecution
originate uh it originated with all
these da's it originated in los angeles
san francisco oakland now chicago
philadelphia uh and the we find out what
waukesha the attorney general there he's
like i am the grandfather that i gave
birth to all these crazy uh da's around
the country and and of all people
commissioner bratton said don't tell me
about the mayor don't tell me about the
police chief tell me about the da's he
said that yesterday he says it's george
soros is fun hardly a conspiracy
theorist what i'm wondering is this and
you're probably the only one equipped to
answer this because you always think
deep i was gonna i was gonna ask you why
that color qualification was okay okay
um
why is she saying this now she's like
you said she's not she's never been dumb
she's like i can't believe people are
doing this not because they're hungry
it's because they're making money off it
because they're selling it uh you know
this is organized
we know this already she knows this
already there's nothing like why is she
saying there's nothing like a 7 65
disapproval rating for the democrats on
crime to you know to like wake up your
thing is she just waking up now is it
disastrous
so out of control a reporter asked her
about that at her briefing but she had
to answer but that was when and she
followed mayor london breed saying the
same thing so i'm sure they are all
because this is a watershed moment this
could change everything she says she
says it's great that the mayor is doing
that and people are saying and like they
had a press conference today white house
press conference they said more mayors
should be asking that question and more
local officials should be asking totally
insincere totally insincere that's my
point it's got to come from the top you
want the money you want doj money you
want burn grants you want federal money
then you better start prosecuting crime
you don't prosecute crime then you don't
get the ability to uh uh to get the
federal monies that you need to run your
office look these rogue d.a's they're
even if they're not prosecuting crime
they're going over old cases and they're
releasing criminals who are convicted
felons convicted many times they're
letting them out they're not even
telling the victims they're just opening
up the doors do you realize if china and
russia and iran are three chief enemies
were going to script the destruction of
america they would get rid of our
history try to work on our foundation
and then make law and order old news
this is exactly
this is we are do we are destroyed from
the inside ourselves abraham lincoln
said it he said if anyone should destroy
this country it will happen from within
right he was right did you know him
geraldo
we used to hang together but
like honestly we've been canceled
right taking off elementary school hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else